porque con nuestro segundo invitado del
día mal evitamos o como está el panorama
político en brasil y el estado de cara a
las elecciones generales con una primera
vuelta el próximo 2 de octubre donde los
brasileños van a escoger un nuevo
presidente de acuerdo con los resultados
de una encuesta divulgada ayer lunes por
el instituto y pec el ex presidente luiz
inácio lula da silva se mantiene como el
favorito para ganar con el 44 por ciento
de la intención de voto una ventaja de
12 puntos porcentuales de su principal
rival en la actual mandataria y el
bolsón ario que obtendría el 32 por
ciento de los sufragios según el sondeo
sin embargo con estas cifras lula no
ganarían la primera vuelta por lo que un
balotaje tendría lugar el próximo 30 de
octubre son 12 ya los candidatos que se
van a disputar la presidencia de la
república con los respectivos
vicepresidentes además se van a elegir a
gobernadores y también se va a renovar
el congreso quiere saludar entonces en
este momento a martín morales analista y
socio en arco international ubicado en
washington dice gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
martín muy buena mañana empezamos con el
panorama político cohen brasil lula
ganaría entonces la presidencia de ese
país
bueno la verdad es que en este momento
la elección se puede considerar que es
una zona abierta
en la campaña puede llegar a cambiar
algo y hay que tener en cuenta que
bolsonaro
todavía tiene chances y está haciendo
todo lo posible para por ejemplo
incrementar el gasto social
cosas que le pueden ayudar a ganar
terreno de aquí a la segunda vuelta
y también por otro lado hay que tener en
cuenta que los electores de brasil son
pragmáticos y no van a elegir a un
candidato en este momento porque lo
apoyan más sino que es una elección
distinta y más que nada los votantes una
ir en contra de quien quieren menos
entonces el nivel de rechazo de ambos
candidatos es bastante alto
yo diría que las de la primera vuelta
o sea está definida en que ambos
candidatos van a van a ir al balotaje
pero no diría que la elección está 100%
definió claro no está 100% definida pero
digamos que las encuestas apuntarían a
una ventaja del candidato del
expresidente luiz inácio lula da silva
pero hablando digamos del rechazo usted
dijo que pues los brasileros votan al
candidato que no quieren más o sea en
contra de ese candidato el cual ha sido
los motivos de la impopularidad del
actual mandatario hecha y revolucionario
digamos que sus políticas y su forma de
ser le han jugado en contra digamos de
cara a estas elecciones presidenciales
del próximo octubre
básicamente el manejo de la pandemia fue
un tema clave a la hora de evaluar sus
políticas y además el tema económico va
a ser un tema clave a la hora de las
campañas de ambos candidatos
tenemos niveles de inflación es que no
son muy comunes para brasil el año
pasado estábamos hablando de un 4% y
ahora ya estamos hablando de un 10% 11%
anual
y principalmente
lo el impacto más fuerte se siente
básicamente en la canasta básica los los
precios de la comida siguen subiendo y
más allá de que la media en este momento
bajo claro martín también a los hicimos
un poco el sistema electoral del gigante
suramericano digamos o es que tan fuerte
y qué tan protegido está este sistema
electoral se lo digo por las constantes
críticas del actual mandatario de
presionar a que se pueden presentar
fraude en estas elecciones de octubre
digamos históricamente en brasil es se
han presentado casos de fraude unas
elecciones tan importantes como las
generales tenía más presidentes a elegir
gobernadores y también pues congresistas
pero eso eso lo conversamos después pero
qué tan fuerte es el sistema brasilero
electoral en este momento
es muy fuerte es muy confiable el tema
de la retórica de bolsonaro para en
contra de la institución de la elección
básicamente se queda en la retórica y no
está fundamentada en absolutamente nada
uno de los temas más importantes del día
de hoy es que va a asumir alexandrou
moráis como
jefe del tribunal superior electoral y
básicamente esto implica que su
principal trabajo va a ser fortalecer la
institución y evitar cualquier tema que
pueda disminuir la credibilidad del
sistema democrático brasilero
su principal trabajo va a ser este y
además combatir todo lo que tiene que
ver con las noticias falsas
y este personaje
es una persona muy importante
porque tiene muchísimas causas de
corrupción además de su actual trabajo
tiene muchísimas causas de corrupción en
contra de la familia
de bolsonaro y es una persona que es su
principal contrincante
a la hora de
hablar sobre la política
y la justicia que es un tema muy muy muy
polémico para evolucionar claro también
cuáles son digamos más allá de las
elecciones presidenciales vamos a hablar
de las gobernaciones cuáles serían las
más importantes que se van a votar este
este 2 de octubre no yo creo que todas
son muy importantes estamos hablando de
un nivel de elección muy muy grande y va
a definir la gobernabilidad de acá a los
próximos años a diferencia de otros
países donde el sistema es un poco más
dividido donde tenemos elecciones
todo el año esta vez en brasil se da que
la elección tiene un impacto muy fuerte
en el resto de los de los años
el caudal más importante de votos
obviamente está en los centros urbanos y
ahí van a ser lugares clave de poder
para
para definir su apoyo al próximo
presidente entonces yo creo que ahí son
los lugares más importantes claro
martingalas también de una
gobernabilidad no en cuanto también en
las votaciones del congreso como
estarían perfiladas estas votaciones
hacia qué partido digamos se inclinarían
en las votaciones al partido de los
trabajadores cómo llega o si no pues a
los seguidores desde el presidente ella
y por el sónar o como ves esas fuerzas
en el congreso cómo funciona bueno el
tema del congreso en brasil es muy
particular es un lugar donde hay
diferentes partidos hay muchísimos
partidos y se gobierna a través de
coaliciones
evolucionaron en este momento y tiene el
apoyo de la colisión del centro que lo
ayudó en su gobierno y básicamente el
poder real se encuentra ahí y no en el
presidente entonces esto es un tema
clave a la hora de definir cuáles son
los
los temas las políticas que van a poder
llevar adelante los presidentes entonces
es muy necesario formar una coalición
fuerte pero también que puede hacer una
colisión receptiva de diferentes voces
para atraer más votos y poder llevar
adelante cualquier política que la
presidencia quiera
claro martín también son 12 los
candidatos que se van a presentar a
estas elecciones de octubre digamos que
más allá de jair bolsonaro y de lula da
silva habría un candidato entre estas
dos que pudieran una sorpresa o ya
digamos que todo estaba definido entre
evolucionaron y lula
ciro gomes es el candidato que les sigue
a estos dos que son más fuertes pero el
el nivel y el caudal de votos que tiene
en este momento él es muy bajo estamos
hablando entre un 5 y un 8 por ciento
entonces
esto de la tercera vía que se estuvo
hablando mucho tiempo durante los
últimos dos años o dos los últimos seis
meses diría que no va a suceder y las
probabilidades son muy muy bajas pero lo
que hay que tener en cuenta es que a la
hora del ballottage los votantes de ciro
gómez son un poco más cercanos a las
posturas o las políticas de lula y no de
bolsonaro ciro gomes está en este
momento criticando a ambos candidatos
con mucha fuerza está hablando próximo
de los dos pero
se podría llegar a decir de que es una
persona de centroizquierda entonces se
podría decir que los votos de de ciro
podrían llegar a beneficiar en su
mayoría la luna